drapeau argentin il nationale sur la
plaza des maillots devant la casa rosada
siège du gouvernement
des milliers d'argentins viennent crier
leur colère
en cause le scandale des vaccinations
vip le 19 février dernier un journaliste
déclare en direct à la radio avoir été
vacciné grâce à ses liens avec le
ministre de la santé
ginès gonzalez garcia comme un effet
domino cette révélation met en lumière
toute une série de passe-droit vaccinaux
accordés à des proches du gouvernement
ginès gonzalez garcia est contraint à la
démission
les argentins eux sont excédés je suis
indignée car nous attendons le vaccin
mon mari a été enfermé pendant six mois
il a perdu sa voix à cause de cet homme
qui nous a gardés en fermer parce qu'il
nous a gardés enfermé et maintenant nous
avons le courage de sortir alors nous
allons sortir
nous devons nous battre le fait qu'ils
aient vacciner des personnes qui
n'avaient pas le bon âge mais juste
parce qu'ils sont proches du pouvoir ne
me surprend pas car c'est typique de ces
personnes au total une liste de 70 nom a
été rendu public
parmi eux le ministre de l'économie
martin goodman 38 ans et des membres de
son cabinet eux aussi pour la plupart
trentenaires alors qu'en principe
seul le personnel soignant et les plus
de 80 ans sont prioritaires pour la
vaccination dans le pays
treize plaintes ont été déposées contre
le ministre de la santé
mais pour le président argentin aucun
crime n'a été commis
mettons fin à ces absurdités je demande
au procureur et au juge de faire ce
qu'il doit faire il n'y a pas de lois
pénales en argentine qui disent toute
personne qui bâtit une autre personne
qui a sauté la fidh attente sera puni
alberto fernandez n'a par ailleurs pas
exclu d'autres démissions selon le
gouvernement 1 millions d'argentins ont
déjà été vaccinées
buenos ars a reçu plus d'un million de
doses du vaccin russe pour nick v 580000
ducobu cheadle indien sérum institut et
plus de 900 mille autres du laboratoire
chinois sinovac